when you say woke you know it's become
and I make fun of it too because it's
become an eye roll I only heard it I
don't know what it was three four years
ago five years ago at most when we heard
the term woke and it was like alert to
Injustice okay I'm down with that yes it
became sort of a by word for a lot of
this goofy stuff my politics hasn't
changed they've changed five years ago
no one was talking about defunding the
police I never heard that phrase five
years ago letting three-year-olds decide
what gender they are this wasn't
something five years ago Free Speech you
know used to be a left-wing thing that
we were proud and owned and now that
seems to be under attack you're right
you haven't changed but the Liberals
have